[Musique]
jamais été auparavant jamais vu de neige
auparavant dans le sud l'air sent
la merde de porc
vous n'êtes jamais allé dans le sud je suis allé
à Winterfell c'est le nord
je pense qu'il y a toujours des surprises pour les
personnages et écoutez vous savez que Jon
Snow a entendu parler  Jorah pendant toute sa
vie, ce vendeur notoire d'esclaves,
puis bien sûr la personne réelle
se présente et John peut voir qu'il est un homme bon John
est tout au sujet de l'honneur et il a un
sens de cette arme incroyable qu'il
a dans ta famille depuis  des siècles,
ce n'est pas bien pour moi de l'avoir Je pense que
John et Jorah établissent une connexion qui
évolue au cours de ce voyage et il y a
une histoire commune qui était un amour de mon
père J'ai perdu le droit de revendiquer
cette chanson tout ce que fait Jorah
concerne  demander pardon c'est à vous
il y a un sentiment de fermeture pour lui en
disant non il vous l'a donné et
je ne mérite pas ça  oui eh bien
je veux dire le hoenn ne parle pas vraiment
beaucoup et ça va être notre
conversation bourrue le chien c'est un
gars très difficile de devenir ami avec
tous ceux qu'ils appelaient le chien va te faire [ __ ]
ce n'est pas du tout le gars bavard - je
veux  faire des bébés avec un grand milliard de
monstres, ils ont conquis le monde,
comment un [ __ ] comme toi a-t-il vécu
aussi longtemps
[Musique]
Je pense que le thème courant, il semble à
tout un parent avec Ganges, vous savez le manque
de famille, c'est la chose qu'il a vue
chercher il est  en quelque sorte à la recherche de
substituts je voulais être l'un d'entre vous je
voulais rejoindre la Confrérie mais tu
m'as vendu un sentiment de trahison je me sens
blessé tu sais certainement n'a pas quitté
Genji tu sais ce qu'elle m'a fait elle
m'a attaché  le lit qu'elle
m'a déshabillé soupire bien jusqu'à présent je pense
que c'était assez embarrassant de la voir
ouais nous n'étions pas un malgré ne jamais la revoir
mais tu sais que tu es parti avec
Melisandre ce n'était pas un mauvais bon garçon
tellement content de  ne fais pas partie de  ce
groupe hétéroclite, il arrive à sortir pour retourner
en Islande quand cette herse arrive
et nous sortons
Magnificent Seven bien qu'il
ne sorte pas vraiment avec -5 tu sais que ça
va démarrer
[Musique]
Aria a ce morceau de
des preuves très incriminantes contre Sansa alors
elle va le chercher et elle ne le
trouve pas mais elle trouve un sac plein de
visages coupés à la place, ce qui est effrayant
, puis sa sœur apparaît sans
aucun son plus effrayant toujours pas ce que vous avez l'
air pécheur et comme ils deviennent  dans la
discussion sur ce que sont ces visages,
elle commence à voir Aria, il y a un réel
danger physique pour elle, les visages d'un homme gay
ne se sont pas si bien passés pour la dernière
personne qui m'a posé des questions, dites-moi dans
quoi ils vont dans le dernier
épisode,
je  pense que Sansa apporte avec elle une
vraie peur à propos de l'idée que la zone pourrait
vraiment vouloir l'assassiner c'est une peur
que Littlefinger Stokes de manière experte est
que ce qu'elle pense je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle pense je ne la connais plus
nous savions que  si nous devions les envoyer au
nord pour les faire traverser des
paysages enneigés, cela vous mènerait si loin,
surtout une fois qu'il y a un gros
ours polaire zombie au milieu, à un
certain moment, vous devez trouver l'armée
des morts, nous pensions comment  pouvez-vous
survivre à cette situation
qui était la chose la plus difficile pour nous, nous en sommes
venus progressivement à l'idée que la seule
façon pour eux de survivre est d'être au
milieu d'une île et ensuite vous mettez
cinq ou dix mille blancs sur cette glace
venant après eux que cela pourrait
vraisemblablement être quelque chose qui briserait
la glace d'une manière qu'ils n'ont pas fait à un
certain moment, ils se battent juste pour
leur survie
une fois qu'ils se sont retirés jusqu'au
milieu du lac, il n'y a nulle part
plus loin  courir, elle a toujours été prête
à risquer sa vie pour faire ce qu'elle pense
être juste et en termes d'aller au nord pour les
sauver, un certain nombre de personnes là-haut
ont des revendications différentes sur son cœur et
Jorah a été à ses côtés depuis le
début et il lui a sauvé la vie tellement de
fois que je pense qu'elle se sentirait comme si
c'était une trahison si elle n'essayait pas au moins
de le sauver et puis bien sûr il y
avait Jon Snow, vous avez définitivement le
sentiment qu'il est devenu assez important
pour  elle et je suis à peu près sûr que lui au
moment où il voit qu'ils vont tous mourir
si le dragon n'enlève pas la
décision rationnelle à ce moment-là, c'est que
vous allez en sécurité et nous essaierons de les
éloigner de vous  tant que je peux
, c'est le gars qui saute sur la grenade pour
sauver le reste du peloton qui a
toujours été John, le truc avec les mains froides,
c'est que le dernier à travailler d'une manière ou d'une autre
dans un délai assez compressé parce
qu'il n'y a tout simplement pas le temps dont
nous avons besoin  le lien émotionnel froid
et dur pour les convaincre très
rapidement de faire ce que je dis et la
façon la plus simple pour lui de le faire est de
montrer son visage John doit en quelque sorte
respecter la décision parce qu'il vient de faire
la même chose le froid et moi  pense que c'est
presque un soulagement à certains égards parce que
il a été pris au piège dans ce genre d'
état de purgatoire entre la vie et la mort
pendant un certain temps et comme tant
de personnages de la série attendant de
savoir quel est son but, vous savez
pourquoi est-il toujours en vie alors qu'il devrait être
mort
et pour lui  il semble qu'il ait trouvé son
but au cours de ces deux dernières saisons en
sauvant la première marque et maintenant John, je pense
que quand elle le voit revenir sur le
dos du cheval de Colton, c'est un grand
moment pour elle en termes de ce qu'elle
ressent pour lui, je ne  Je ne pense pas que l'un ou
l'autre savait vraiment à quel point
leurs sentiments étaient puissants l'un envers l'autre
jusqu'à ces moments, juste l'idée de
tomber amoureux de quelqu'un qui s'est impliqué.
Bien sûr, je
pense qu'ils sont tous les deux sur un
terrain peu familier et surtout parce que
c'est avec un égal, c'est un peu difficile pour
elle à ce moment-là, je pense qu'il ne faut pas regarder
ce gars et j'ai réalisé que ce n'est pas
l  comme les autres garçons,
les dragons sont mes enfants, ils sont les
seuls enfants 11 comprenez-vous
[Musique
] tout le cheminement de la série avait en quelque
sorte essayé de cartographier tous les
points de fin de l'épisode et avec celui-ci
c'était le dragon  ouvrant son œil bleu et
réalisant que le roi bleu nuit a
finalement obtenu sa propre arme de
destruction massive, ce qui était amusant dans la
séquence que vous connaissez terriblement bien pour nous, c'est
que jusqu'à la fin, c'est très proche d'
une de ces batailles où tous les bons
gars  sortez de l'autre côté et plus ou
moins indemne, mais nous savions que tuer
le dragon allait avoir un
impact émotionnel énorme car au fil des
saisons et des saisons de la série, on a
vraiment souligné ce qu'ils sont pour
Danny, nous savions que le roi de la nuit
verrait et saisirait cette opportunité aimerait
penser que lorsque le Dragon meurt,
c'est une sorte de coup de poing parce que
d'une part, vous voyez juste l'
horreur de l'un de ces trois
êtres incroyables comme celui-ci dans le monde
sous l'eau et ne pas remonter
et traiter cela, alors vous traitez
quelque chose qui est encore pire,
c'est-à-dire quand il ressort à nouveau de
sous l'eau et nous voyons dans le
dernier plan de l'épisode ce que cela devient
[Musique]
Jeu de  Thrones Assessor set
non-exclusivité Yoshimi 10m Iglesias
COCs bouquet bleu supposez que notre cinéma
désolé
visite OCS amusant vous voyez
alors je suis habitué aux ennemis de l'est à l'
ouest ennemis au sud ennemis au
nord tout ce qui se dresse sur notre chemin nous le
vaincrons  avec les Lannister,
je suis né pour gouverner les Sept Royaumes
et je le ferai
[Musique]
leur père et leurs frères sont partis mais
ici vous êtes le
dernier meilleur espoir contre la tempête à venir
si nous ne mettons pas de côté nos inimitiés et que
nous nous unissons, nous mourrons
et  alors peu importe dont le
squelette est assis sur le trône de fer
[Musique]
la Grande Muraille est-il Game of Thrones une
saison qui le distingue Je ne suis pas d'accord SEO
OCS lubu Quezon City Missouri
Oh CS était-ce amusant tu vois
[Musique]
toi